welcome everyone my name is camila and i
will be the moderator for this session
i'm very happy to be here welcome to pi
data global 2021.
i would like now to welcome
naomi
and i'm just going to quickly read here
her bio
naomi said she earned a phd in classic
several decades ago
but switched from ancient human
languages to computer language sometime
in the last century since 2021 she has
been learning teaching writing about and
using python
an elected fellow of the python software
foundation naomi's the immediate past
chair of its boards of directors she
also speaks internationally about the
python community and on inclusion and
diversity in technology in general
by day she leads a team of python
programmers for big bleak art materials
and in her spare time she enjoys
sketching knitting and deep
philosophical conversations with her dog
and she's going to present us
with the keynote bow of confusion the
word data and ethics welcome naomi
ah
thank you thank you um so
yeah
let's let's get started i guess and um
yeah i'm naomi uh i used to be a chair
of the python software foundation uh i
guess i would say these days i'm pretty
much nobody and that's fine uh and
actually i even mentioned that just to
emphasize that uh in in this talk and
pretty much all of my talks these days i
am speaking only for myself
um i am not speaking on behalf of the
python software foundation or anybody
else this is purely my opinion
and um yeah i guess i guess i have to
say a bunch of things about uh what i'm
not and what this is not um
so i i would not call myself a data
scientist
certainly certainly not an expert in
ai or machine learning or anything like
that
on the other hand
i have
been wrangling data in various sizes of
data sets
for the past 25 years
so i have i have some experience with
that world i guess i would say uh i
would also feel obligated to say that i
am i am not an expert on ethics nor am i
a philosopher
uh but again on the other hand i did
spend over 20 years uh teaching in a
high school where i was a student
advisor so i did hear my share of of
ethical questions then
and
i also
as a grad student in classics many years
ago i ended up reading
significant chunks of plato lucretius
marcus aurelius uh augustine
and and others in their original uh
languages and
sometimes afterwards argued about them
over beers with people from the
philosophy department so i've got that
connection i guess uh and of course
having having led the psf and served on
conduct committees and even on uh
corporate leadership teams from time to
time i i have seen that side of dealing
with the question of ethics
and i suppose i'm partly feeling
obligated to
uh mention all of this by way of
disclaimer because i actually
thought i would try ai to see if i was
qualified
to to give this talk so i checked with
the ask delphi which is an experimental
uh ai ethics engine whether or not it
was ethical for me not being an expert
in either of those fields to talk at
this conference and it said no
uh so so there you have it um
and um
i also know that there was a series of
short talks on ethics earlier today i
i'm sorry i was not able to to attend
that they looked very interesting indeed
and i'm sure they probably had far more
meaningful things to say than i will say
but that's that's not going to stop me
uh i will then and sort of at the end of
all of these things that this is not
tell you that this is not a bunch of
answers because i really only have uh
questions and and issues and problems
here um
and by now you may have noticed the
other thing that this talk is uh is is
not is
we do not have slides
uh i i have no data i have no graphs i
have no code i do have i will tell you
uh a strong almost superstitious belief
that the vast majority of slide
presentation slides
do nothing other than actively suck the
intelligence out through your eyeballs
so i do not i do not like them and i
avoid them what i can and here i can so
instead i will abuse zoom's background
feature
which actually now is is an advanced
feature if you actually have a zoom
license but i'm too cheap so i don't uh
but uh to to show a bunch of pictures
and if you're very good i will change
these pictures from time to time and you
can amuse yourself by figuring out what
the heck i was thinking when i chose the
pictures
so
that's that's all kind of by way of my
long introduction and and disclaimer
so i watched uh dave's talk keynote on
thursday
because i i never miss a chance to to
hear dave speak uh and and he had some
pretty cool stuff he had lightning he
had the beast uh pretty hard to top
lightning and the beast but i do have
one advantage over dave and that is that
i am older so uh he started in 1994 i
can see that and raised by about 25
years i can actually start in 1970
okay and in 1970 i will tell you i was i
was a 13 year old little white bread
nerd uh growing up in a tiny little farm
town in the middle of nebraska middle of
nowhere uh but even i
in 1970 knew that the temptations were
darn cool
uh the temptations in case you're not
familiar with them uh were probably the
r b and doo-wop band of the 60s and 70s
uh and their music is everywhere if
you're not aware of them you've still
heard their music everywhere uh i
heartily recommend that you go on your
favorite music service and look up the
temptations and listen to a bunch of
temptation stuff uh you will definitely
uh appreciate it uh so you know you're
you're welcome um
but the um
the the thing about the temptations in
1970 was that it was in the early summer
uh of 1970
that uh
they came out with a song called ball of
confusion that's what our world is today
and as i was thinking about the themes i
wanted to talk about for this talk it
struck me that it was almost uncanny how
that um
that song
reflected uh those times which i do
remember and our times uh i i thought
about playing it for you but then i
decided that well first of all
those things almost never work
technically something always goes wrong
and the host ends up fighting with the
the technology nah don't want to do it
secondly given uh the dcm uh
ca software and and the anti-pirating
things it would probably get flagged for
having you know illegal content so i'm
not going to be able to play it for you
but i can't refer to uh some of the
lyrics that kind of explain why it is
i it came to mind uh one of the early
verses talks about segregation
determination demonstration integration
aggravation humiliation obligation to
our nation uh and then further on uh eve
of destruction tax
tax deduction city inspectors bill
collectors mod clothes on demand
population out of hand suicide too many
bills hippies moving to the hills people
all over the world are shouting in the
war
so i mean clearly there are some
references that are very topical there
for uh um
for uh
you know uh the world in 1970 uh there
is a reference to the latest beetle
singles of gas but a lot of this i think
speaks to us here in uh
2021
as well
so that was that was the inspiration if
you happen to be wondering about why
this is a ball of confusion uh that's
what i'm thinking of
and of course the the second part of my
title
um was the world data and ethics so the
world
uh the world right now uh i think we
have a number of of interesting things
going on it has been
as they say a time uh
so we are now
we hope uh working our way through uh
the pandemic uh we're certainly not out
yet
uh and and certainly it's not going to
be plain sailing but there are signs at
least that eventually we will work our
way through this to a point that um
things are are a little bit back to more
like they used to be in what we have
come to call the before times
uh however
you know as as the pandemic started
i know i started talking a little bit
and thinking a little bit about the
effects that the pandemic would have
uh on
on the world and on particularly on our
communities uh you know our python
communities our communities in general
and
i have to admit that some things i
thought about i got right
pretty much from from the beginning of
the pandemic i was worried that it would
have a a very deleterious very negative
effect
on education
and i think that's kind of been borne
out
um there there are a lot of things like
that uh but there was one thing that i
got uh really enormously wrong i missed
totally that is when the pandemic
started
i
thought
that there would be a a negative effect
economically for everyone i thought that
we were going to go into
perhaps a global depression
um
i guess this is a good illustration of
why
i am not an economist because i got that
totally wrong
however to be fair i think the economist
got it wrong too
and in fact the striking thing about the
uh
pandemic economically has been the
disparity
of the effect that it's had
so
certainly for the poorest people uh the
pandemic has had a very negative effect
in addition to losing uh their lives to
losing loved ones people have lost their
livelihoods people have lost their homes
some people have have have really been
economically practically wiped out uh or
certainly suffered quite a bit
uh on the other hand at the other end of
the scale
people who are moderately well-off let's
say people like many of us who are able
to
stay home in safety and work and get
paid through the pandemic we came out
not bad maybe even a little bit ahead of
where we were
and then people at the very high end of
the scale the billionaires that we hear
so much about uh actually
profited actually gained from the
pandemic and they gained an obscene
amount of money
this disparity as i say this this wealth
disparity uh in the midst of a pandemic
i did not see coming
uh and you know similarly we we have
other things going on we we are facing
climate change
uh i would hope now that there is nobody
uh
reasonably reasonably rational who
really doubts the fact that climate is
changing but here again i think what
we're going to see as as as an important
effect of this uh not just that the
climate will degenerate of course it is
this is happening but again we're going
to see this disparity
uh the very richest are going to be i
promise you just fine and i will even
bet that the very richest will find a
way to come out ahead in climate change
okay then a lot of the people who are
fairly well off will probably be okay at
least for a while
uh but it will be the people the very
poorest people wherever they might be
who are going to be the ones suffering
the most
they will be the ones who will suffer
from loss of their livelihoods uh who
will suffer from scarcity of food who
will suffer from loss of their homes who
will suffer even loss of their lives
so again we're going to see
this disparity and as i say i expect
i i i hope that i'm wrong but i expect
that the pandemic will end uh pandemic
that climate change will end up having
the same effect as the pandemic in terms
of aggravating this disparity that is is
a growing problem it it is something
that um
it's hard to imagine how we can tolerate
it yet uh it just seems to continue
that of course is
not not the the total list of all of our
problems we are in the midst of an era
of
political separation and polarization
that is um is very concerning uh it does
honestly again make me think back to the
late 60s and early 70s when we had a
similar amount of turmoil uh
in this case maybe we have even more i
don't know
we have issues with
gender equity that that are that we are
struggling to resolve we have uh issues
in dealing with uh justice in terms of
race um in spite of the progress we have
made uh
anti-lgbt phobia and hatred seems to in
many places be on the march again uh
there are just many things like that
that we could go on and on about that
are
things that
i guess
are why i say yes the the the notion
that that we are living in a ball of
confusion strikes me as quite apt
and of course this world is is the
context for us as we live and work for
us as professionals it's the context for
the data that we extract it's the
context for the data systems that we
build uh we are all part of this world
we none of the things that we do really
are are
extracted from it so as i say that's
that's the world uh a ball of confusion
that's what our world is today as the
band said
so
the other part of that
was of course uh data
and um
the amount of data
that that we now have
sort of to deal with
uh
is has has grown in a in a striking way
over the past 20 years
uh if you even keep things on a shorter
time frame um five years ago in 2016
there was an estimate
that uh
we were storing 18 zettabytes of data uh
that that is just an impossibly
large number i you know a number that is
impossible to man imagine meaningfully
um and yet now five years later we have
nearly not quite but nearly five times
as much data being stored
that that's that's just a weird number
really uh
and
interesting interesting to me at least
um
the vast majority of that uh over 80
percent is is unstructured data so you
know tax logs captures whatever it might
be
um
and another thing that is is a little
bit weird with the the stats that you
can find on data is that again the vast
majority maybe in the neighborhood of 90
of that data is not
not what you might call original data uh
it's it's replicated in some way it's
it's copies backup copies uh cooked data
extracts uh somehow modified but
basically deriving from another data
source which i find interesting
and finally and it's it's it's really
hard to come up with
recent uh estimates on this but it looks
like from from the things that i have
found that uh only a tiny fraction
of this data that we store
probably somewhere below one percent of
it
is actually analyzed so we have an
increasing mountain of data
and yet we are actually
using very very little of it
so
that that is strikes me as just an
interesting um
uh sort of picture of what has happened
uh and really the amount of data that we
had say before 2000 uh is
you know invisibly tiny compared to
where we are today uh having been around
and actually having been a professional
working with data in 2000 uh this
strikes me as as as just kind of amazing
so
what do we do with this data
well i mean we do a lot of things and
obviously this these these three days
have been dedicated to the many you know
interesting and cool and and beneficial
things we can do
uh but there's a lot of what we do with
data that i think has
has raised issues in various ways
so you know we have
for example deep fakes
and deep fakes can be amusing if they're
mona lisa mugging for the camera
certainly uh on the other hand if maybe
it's a deep fake that is influencing uh
a political outcome
i find that rather troubling i don't
know about you
uh
and um interestingly a couple weeks ago
i caught a talk uh that was hosted by
our local acm chapter here uh from a
woman whose dissertation was on
detecting deep fakes
and it turns out that um the the actual
shape and the subtle movements of of the
ear uh are
are a giveaway uh for deep fakes these
days oh it sounds cool you know good for
her uh but it then led me to to the
additional thought that's like wait a
second so
somebody did
a bunch of a bunch of work a bunch of of
work uh in in terms of uh
you know machine learning models and and
and all of that that you know a ton of
data went into uh creating deep fakes
okay and now we have somebody who has
done also a ton of work and and
sophisticated models and all of that to
detect deep fakes uh
presumably to help counter their
negative effects
and what this will lead to of course is
somebody else doing a ton of uh work and
creating models and all of that to make
better deep vagues
so that uh it can avoid the detection
and
so it will go
um
there are other things that that that
you know we're using our data for so uh
facial recognition comes to mind
which again is
is convenient if it unlocks your phone
it's convenient if maybe just a little
bit creepy if it gets you onto an
airplane without having to show your
ticket
and then if in fact it's being used by a
government or a police force to to
arrest either people either
for a crime or for for being a dissident
that becomes much more troubling
in my mind
so um you know as as the ban says the uh
the ban plays on
we also have have seen
our social networks
no need to name them we all know they
are that are not at all above um
sort of
modifying their algorithms and their
models so that they can uh promote
uh division and disinformation if it
happens to favor their bottom line
uh
we have
uh
what else we have autonomous vehicles
we also now have
uh autonomous weapons again gives me
pause
we are using our data to predict who
might commit a crime sometimes with
great bias
or who might be a good employee
also oftentimes with great bias
many many things like that we have uh
national natural language processing
systems that can create human-like text
even though as as somebody called them
uh they really are little more than
stochastic parrots
and i just like that phrase stochastic
parrots mark my words i'm saving that as
my insult of choice uh going forward for
people who simply repeat things without
understanding them
so
we're doing a lot of things like this
okay
and
in addition to that we as professionals
in this ecosystem
uh
are are also uh dealing with um
organizations companies whatever that
have had struggles with uh diversity
equity and inclusion
uh whatever that might be but those
problems are are are fairly common and
particularly those of us who might not
fall into one of the favored groups uh
have to deal with that
uh we may be working for companies who
do not share our our ethical values
i had a lead developer once who had a
rule about jobs that was no guns no
banks
uh okay fine i mean i i respect that uh
but what happens if the company you're
working for gets bought by a bank i mean
i think
a fair number of people find themselves
in awkward situations that way
um
and of course even if we are releasing
uh uh or or working within an open
source ecosystem on an open source
project um in most cases there is no
control to keep that work that project
from being used by people who who may be
using it uh what we would say
unethically
so
so we have all of these
all of these things going on
and
uh i think that you know in general uh
most people agree that these things have
an ethical dimension to them that
actually ethics is at the heart of a
number of these a number of these issues
um
and
um yeah i mean sometimes they will
suggest technical things like if we only
had more data if we only had a better
more complex algorithm these things
would go away
in general i don't personally at least
find that to be a totally convincing
argument
certainly it might help
so what about this ethics stuff then
you know um
i think that we generally have a feeling
uh within our communities within within
you know our practitioners who are
working with data uh and probably in the
world generally as far as that goes
that that
you know their ethics is is a good thing
uh and there have been a certain number
of uh efforts uh to uh
to maine to to i guess increase uh the
way that we use ethics to deal with some
of these issues um there is now a
movement to embed ethics instruction
into a computer science curricula in
universities
and
that's certainly a good thing
i i it can't be the only thing that we
rely on that would be a case of too
little too late i think
but it's certainly not a bad idea
there are people who are working on
ethical source licenses
and
there are groups that are working on
codes of ethics for data professionals
i'll touch on those a little bit later
because i think in general we can look
at
other professions
and we can see that uh you know a code
of ethics and established code of ethics
is something that a lot of professions
use
as a way to um give credibility and and
confidence in that profession and its
professionals
and i think you know more important than
that uh having having a clear coat of
ethics uh can help give everyone kind of
a moral center
that that helps them make decisions in
in ambiguous situations so so all of
that i think is is definitely a good
idea
um
the problem is
i would say and and i i don't think
you'll find a lot of people who are
really happy with where we are i would
say that um
in many ways uh
that sort of ethical stuff has not been
applied where it needs to in in the
context of companies or governments or
whatever
and i think part of the reason for that
is that in setting
uh a code of ethics uh quite often the
people who are actually determining that
uh may not have an understanding of the
technology or the context that is used
maybe they do but in most cases
certainly in the case of government
regulation uh it seems to me that that
they are are quite often done with
almost a deliberate disregard for the
realities of of the technology and its
use
uh and on the other hand those those uh
ethical solutions may be proposed by
people who are not really aiming
to
to to make an ethical fix they're doing
it for political or financial or
business reasons in a way
so i think that's that's part of the
issue
uh i've also noticed and i think many
people have seen this as well that um
ethics seems to be an afterthought you
know it's kind of the thing where you
know if we get our series c funding
we'll hire somebody for hr and they'll
worry about ethics something like that
uh
and
finally i we the other place where we
see ethical solutions sort of attempting
to be applied is
uh
in response to maybe a specific issue or
problem
uh you know if if a company has has
managed to have a huge data leak or
something like that uh almost certainly
they will commit themselves uh to better
practices
and commit themselves to being ethical
with people's data and respecting
privacy and you will hear them say
things like we take your privacy very
seriously
um
yeah sure
or or or similarly maybe issues of
transparency
clearly if there is something involving
diversity equity and inclusion
a company or organization has
discriminated against
its members or against someone else or
something like that they will commit
themselves to having
more ethical policies around diversity
equity and inclusion and and respecting
that and they will always say this is
not who we are and this is just kind of
a footnote from somebody who's been
watching these things for many years now
uh when an organization says this is not
who we are
uh
what that almost always means is
unfortunately this is who we are but
we're hoping we can talk you out of
paying attention to it
so um you know those things are all
there and those things have not
in my in my mind and again i would i
would say probably in most people's
minds those things have not addressed uh
some of the ethical questions that that
we would hope they would uh
and and in fact the ethical questions
remain
and and these efforts quite often end up
doing you know pretty much nothing
and that
for me is kind of an interesting
question right
uh why is that
um
and um
it's
it's you know always interesting when
you have this bunch of bright people who
can solve problems and there's this
obvious thing and for some reason it
just can't seem to get done why is that
and there are a number of reasons for
this
there's one though that i don't think
gets gets very much attention and that's
the one that i want to focus on
and that is
the way that we
view our systems in the way that we
approach problems and problem solving
uh so um
we tend to
i if we have any exposure to science or
engineering or things like that we tend
to take a reductionist view of our
systems
and that is
you know viewing a system as a
collection of parts and if you can
understand the parts and then understand
the parts of the parts and the parts of
the parts of the parts and so on all the
way down you can understand the system
uh and this is of course um something
that that that got its start uh
centuries ago uh particularly with with
the two guys that are behind me right
now uh descartes and and newton and then
of course many others this is the way
that we think and this is a way of
thinking that is very successful in a
large number of situations i mean
honestly this sort of reductionist
thinking is why
we are here why we have the
telecommunications in order to have this
conference remotely why we have this
mound of data and and our profession and
all of these things uh comes in large
part to the uh to this approach that was
pioneered those centuries ago
uh the the problem is of course
that it does not always work for all
systems
uh
but if we do have that kind of system
where basically it is the sum of its
parts it's fairly linear one stage leads
to another stage leads to another stage
then if you have a problem
you can solve it by finding the broken
part and fixing it right you know if if
a wing falls off an airplane
presumably you can find where the wing
was attached the airplane you can look
at all the parts find the broken bolt
whatever it might be
and you know what happened and how to
fix it
and you know this leads to
what what some complex systems people
refer to as as the broken part fallacy
or broken part thinking um my my
favorite example i think of this though
in in our business is uh unit tests unit
tests are a classic example of
reductionist thinking uh if we if we
have tests on all of the parts
uh then clearly we shouldn't have a big
problem with the system right because
all of the parts work
uh and we've tested them and we know
they all work and in fact i i don't know
of anybody who writes non-trivial
systems is using software that will
believe that because we know that's not
exactly the whole story
um so
what what is the other part of the story
then what is the the other or at least
one other way of looking at at this
and that would be to think in terms of
of complex systems
and um again i'm not going to complain
claim to to be an an expert uh on the
theory of complex systems there are
people have devoted their careers to
this i've read a couple books so it's
not but in general
a complex system is one where there are
too many parts
and too many possible states uh
for for us to comprehend all of the
possibilities uh in effect they are so
complex that
they're difficult to model and the model
is you know the same size as the system
it's very hard to abstract out one or
two bits to model
and you know i
weather for example is a good example
the classic example of a complex system
uh and within complex systems the the
components
sort of do their own thing they act
locally based on their constraints and
and and and and the inputs locally and
then you know whatever effects they
generate get passed on to other parts
and other parts but there's not a
straight linear progression where if you
start at point a you go through b c d
etc and come out at the other end there
is a complex interaction of things
and that means
with a complex system you can get
emergent behaviors uh they're they're
very hard to pin down as to exactly
where one stage starts and another one
ends
and
that also means that they tend to have
uh non-linear responses to changes in
input uh you know so that a very small
change in some initial condition or some
input can end up having a
a huge effect
somewhere else
uh
and that may or may not be close to
where the initial change was
so this is uh kind of uh you know the
inspiration for the the metaphor of the
butterfly effect
uh that sort of thing uh and it can also
be true with the complex system
that a failure whatever that might be of
a complex system
may or may not be connected to a failing
part
uh it may be a bunch of different parts
failing it may actually be that no part
really actually quote failed but the
interaction of all of those parts uh
ended up producing something that we did
not anticipate that falls into the
category of a failure
so
um that i would argue
is where we're at with
the vast majority of if not virtually
all
of the systems we use processing data
our data the systems that we use to
process our data are almost always
complex systems
it is impossible to know exactly what
every line of our code does in every
possible situation
back when i was doing c in the early 90s
i know
somebody argued that the way that you
could write
bug-free code in c
which is in itself kind of a funny
process funny idea rather if you've
actually tried to write code and see
was to use an interactive debugger and
step through every single line of your
code and every possible branch every
possible state of your code to confirm
that it worked
uh okay even if it might for example be
possible to do that with say a 20 line
function
uh you know you're keeping track of your
uh mccabe uh cyclomatic complexity so
you don't have too many different
branches and all of that you might
actually do that
once you release that 20 line function
into the wild you have no idea
how it's going to interact with the data
that's fed to it and and and you know
what will happen once it returns its
data if it does
so
that i think in my that's certainly my
feeling after after some 30 years of
coding is that in general our software
systems are complex systems
and then
you know we continue from there to
take the the data the decisions what
however you might call it made by a
system like this and feed it into
another system like that which will
again produce a result that gets fed
into yet another system like that and
again none of them know for example
right for you know much for sure about
uh
where the data comes from what's the
condition of the of the data going in
nor do they have any any notion any
control of what will happen with that
data once it goes out
so they're very much components in a
complex system
and i think we can add to that then the
the additional factor of humans doing um
whatever it is they're going to do for
another set of complex complex and
uh often hard to predict reasons
so
that i think
sort of adds up to
a problem in
kind of um
managing this stuff and saying well why
don't we just make our stuff ethical
what's the problem
the problem is
the whole thing is a collection of
complex systems that are working
together and you know it's it's just
sort of all the way down
and that means that
our typical reductionist thinking the
way that we have been trained to think
about uh solving a problem will not help
us unravel this ball of confusion
okay fixing ethics as a component won't
work you can't just find the broken
ethics component
and replace it or fix it
that that does not that's not how it
works
uh
and so when we're thinking about our
systems
i
we we really need to think a little bit
more globally i think it also means that
we can't just have ethics in one part
of our system one part of our
organization without having
an ethical approach everywhere
so
in analyzing and thinking about our
systems and and what we want to do with
them uh we need to think much more
globally we need to think rather than
going down and into the components we
need to kind of go up and out to the the
surrounding context and beyond
so that means we need to consider the
connections with what we're doing with
what's going on in the in the rest of
the world or at least in the rest of our
context we need to consider broader
implications and above all we need to if
we want to behave ethically which i hope
we do
uh we need to have ethics be an integral
part of of the overall systems whether
that's uh you know just
you know a system or our organizations
or our approach to work uh all of that
uh
it also points out that
there is
another way
this brings up another way in which uh
diversity is important
and
i certainly have argued for diversity on
using a number of reasons this is one
that i have not actually used before but
i find it pretty compelling
and that is um
experts
in uh in in complex systems uh
have found that a complex system that is
then optimized
to to reduce its diversity and
redundancy will be much more prone to
catastrophic failure
so that means within our systems if we
want them to be resilient they need to
have a certain amount of of diversity
whatever that might mean
but
in order for that to happen that means
we need to have diversity in the people
creating designing
and guiding those systems
not only
will having a diverse team get you know
help us in terms of creativity uh you
know it's it's kind of been
pretty much known for 60 years that if
you're trying to handle complex problems
the more diverse your team is the more
likely you are to be successful in doing
that
but it's also to to create systems that
themselves have diverse approaches to
things and
this means not just
having
a bunch of different people in the room
it's not just head count
this means that you had they have to
have an impact on the outcome if you
have a hundred very diverse people in
the room but the same one person makes
the decisions all the time based on
their experience that's that's not
meaningful diversity in this sense
so that means that we need to really
practice what we have been talking about
for some time in terms of diversity
equity and inclusion
and that also requires that our
organizations our way of of doing
business our way of dealing with
everybody
has to have an ethical base if not
we will not have
those people so
that that also i think argues for that
and i think finally
another argument for
um
that that this brings up for having a a
an ethical system in place is just that
given the complexity of our systems and
the complexity of our organizations
we we are in situations where there are
many uh decision points where you know
the span of control is is ambiguous uh
where it may not be possible to have a
complete top-down sort of thing
so
we need to have
throughout
sort of a system of ethics in place for
people so that all of those little
decisions along the way
can fit into that ethical framework and
we have a better chance of having an
outcome that that is in some way ethical
so
what does that leave us to do
if you accept any of that um
well
so for one thing we need to increase our
our diversity of people uh in many areas
there's been progress on that in other
areas there's been disappointingly
little
so we need to increase that and it needs
to be again a meaningful inclusion of
people uh in in terms of creating the
final decision not just a head count
we need to as we design and implement
everything we need to continue to
try to force ourselves to think
uh more up and out more beyond the
system more into its context and wider
implications and we need to
uh have some way
to make uh
the the asking of ethical questions
uh and the paying attention to ethical
questions uh an integral part of our
processes of our organizations of of of
how we do things
um so
yeah again i said i had mostly questions
mostly problems those those are kind of
the ones that come to mind
so
yeah you know how are we going to do
that
um
i do have a couple of suggestions
um i don't i don't think i would say
that they're anywhere near being things
that that are our answers
but i do think that we need to be aware
of uh the broader
context as we we go through handling
data and our processes we need to ask
ourselves do we need this piece of data
how are we going to use this piece of
data well this data or with this system
or the data that this system produces
in some way be used to to harm people
will it possibly have a negative effect
uh if
we manage to to use our system to i
don't know uh corner some little bit of
our economy uh and profit uh will that
end up having a devastating effect
somewhere else in the broader system in
the world will we end up uh perhaps
destroying someone's livelihood and in
another part of this complex system that
we inhabit
um we need to in other words make it a
habit to ask ourselves about the wider
impacts and context of what we're doing
um another thing that i think we should
be more aware of is that we can uh at
least take the work that has already
been begun on this topic uh so um there
are
a few projects that have gone on about
uh ethics in data
there are a couple of things the
european commission on ai has produced a
code of ethics relating to
to data and ai
there's the oxford munich code of
conduct relating to to uh
data scientists those are a couple of
places that maybe as we're looking
for
how it is we want to frame our ethics
we can
we can consider those things certainly
we need to promote those projects and
other projects
and i would say participate and shape
them if we can
um
we can possibly
consider
um in in the open source world if we're
releasing software things like that uh
other licensing options uh there is the
ethical source license and other related
uh licenses that attempt to
control the use of something in an
ethical way
um
i i hesitate to think of those as a
final answer uh they strike me as being
an answer to one part of the problem uh
i think i also have a little bit of
concern that uh we have not yet had a
body of ethic of a legal precedent
to to support the effectiveness of that
approach
so uh something that may be worth being
considered but it's still in its early
stages
and finally
of course we can vote with our feet
uh
we in in this business uh have an
enormous amount of leverage right now
collectively
uh people with the skills
that we have those of us in this
conference in our business uh are
increasingly in demand again the pile of
data is is continuing to expand uh
businesses organizations
whoever uh want to want to do something
with that data
and i can tell you
that if
companies need to have and follow
codes of ethics in order to hire people
they will do it uh i've been in various
management discussions where it's like
what do we have to do well if we have to
do this hire people we'll do it so if it
happens to be ethics uh i think
companies will collectively say okay we
can be ethical if we have to i guess uh
if it's a condition for getting the
people that they need
so
we we have
in in that sense the power to insist
that
the companies the organizations the
communities that we are part of uh
follow some sort of code of ethics um we
still have to determine what that is and
and and we still have to follow through
with that leverage to make that happen
but it is something that we can do
so
i guess to wrap this up um
what i'm saying is that um
as humans we actually have
this ability to see beyond
uh just one system and we do have the
ability to look a little bit further and
understand a wider context wider
implications this is something that the
butterfly and the butterfly effect does
not have of course
we can actually learn a little bit and
find out about what
our systems might do and we can think
about what implications they might have
uh we will almost certainly not be right
100 of the time
but i think that we do have that ability
to to look beyond uh and then consider
our actions in the light of something
beyond just uh the the local conditions
the local system our local self-interest
so uh that i would argue is why we need
to to to employ ethics that is the role
i think of of ethics uh
in in this ball of confusion not only as
individuals but businesses organizations
communities uh that ability to to look
beyond and act in a great in the
interest of something greater uh and and
follow an ethical framework to do that
uh is in my opinion
the only way that that we can deal with
this ball of confusion or as the
temptation said you can run run run but
you just can't hide so uh thank you very
much for listening to all of this um
and thank you for having me speak thank
you so much for being with us naomi
thank you so much
i have one question maybe and then we
can close because well you've said many
insightful things one of them that it's
called my attention is like that ethic
seems to be an afterthought
uh
and my question on that is what do you
think we can do to change that that it
starts people start to think that on the
beginning of the process and then not in
the end when things went wrong for
example
i i think that comes down to us as
professionals and what we are willing to
tolerate
um
people
will in general do the things that they
value
so
what what does this mean then you know
if we're willing to to let that pass
then it will continue to be that way i i
think you know in i've seen things
having watched the say the python
community deal with the question of
inclusion and diversity there's still
much work to do but where the python
community was
and you know in attendance at
conferences and in general the inclusion
of people
even 10 years ago compared to now
has been an enormous change because in
fact
the majority of members of the community
would not put up with it not changing
that is what we need to do
perfect
okay so
naomi i thank you so much for your time
and for being here with us
thanks everyone in the audience
thanks so much being here at pi data
global 2021 thank you so much
thank you